it looks like something out of a science
fiction film
a space-age paramedic jetting off to
locate
and treat a stricken hiker but this jet
pack could soon be the way
medics in remote locations and difficult
terrain
reached their patients this simulated
trial in the lake district saw the
response time cut
from 25 minutes to 90 seconds
the idea came as a result really of
being kind of enthralled by
the technology that gravity were using
and just seeing just how kind of
maneuverable it was and wondering
whether there would be an application
to use it in those kind of remote areas
the kit consists of
two mini engines on each arm and a main
pack on the back
which allows the pilot to navigate with
just their hands
richard browning was involved in this
trial and says the future is exciting
the suit we're flying at the moment in
fact there's some behind me um
that's the mark ii suit the mark iii
prototype is sitting just behind the
camera on our development table there
and that starts in 10 seconds instead of
45 seconds for these ones
and flies for more like six or seven
minutes and can carry even more weight
as
well this technology has been around for
some time
in august last year french inventor
frankie zappata succeeded in crossing
the channel
in just 22 minutes his paraffin-powered
device reach speeds of up to 110 miles
per hour
and when dealing with any casualty speed
is always a key
factor for some the jetpack paramedic
could simply deliver rapid pain relief
as they await conventional transport to
hospital
for others those vital minutes could be
the difference between life
and death ended brady sky news